WESLEY CHUN: Hi, everyone.
This is Wesley Chun, engineer
and Developer Advocate.
Here at Google, we
strongly believe
in giving users impactful
and delightful experiences
when using our tools.
Well, we want you to do the
same for your customers.
Today's episode is
all about good times
and how you, with
not much effort,
can enhance the experience
you give your users
by marking up the email
you're already sending them.
But before we talk shop,
let's think about some
of those experiences.
Going out to eat is something
that everyone favors.
Enjoying a night out with
friends or that special someone
shouldn't be stressful.
Technology should help
enhance this experience,
making things easier
and more convenient.
If you're a restaurateur, or
a dining reservation service,
you want your information
available at your customers'
fingertips, meaning
what you don't
want is for them to
be hopping into a cab,
fumbling for the email
app on their phones
and having to search for
your message that confirms
a reservation time
and your address.
Similarly, let's say
you're an online retailer.
When customers buy
something from you,
they care where their stuff is.
Their anxiety can only be
reconciled with the "order
confirmed" and the "order
has shipped" messages
that you send them.
And if you include
the tracking number,
you're further building up
their anticipation to "the day."
But if your message is drowned
out by all the other email
they get, the alternative
is, that precious gift
you bought for your
mom may get all wet.
Well, how would that happen?
Sadly, the traditional
inbox is one-dimensional and
disorganized.
Important and less
important messages
are mixed together,
causing your notifications
to get lost in the shuffle
and users frustrated.
Take a look at the inbox here.
How long does it take you to
find the important messages
indicating that your
order has shipped
and your dining reservation
versus everything else?
Well, the answer is too long.
The real problem is that there's
no relationship between email
messages, important
or otherwise.
So this led the Gmail team to
rethink email and create Inbox,
which has a goal to fix
this problem by highlighting
the key elements
in your messages,
placing them front and
center with beautiful images,
engaging users in an immersive
and joyful experience.
Here in Inbox you see both
the dining reservation
and my online purchase together.
Beyond Inbox, you'll
find that markup also
elevates key information
to other Google services.
Look!
That dinner reservation
is on my Google Calendar
so I don't forget.
On the day of, a Google Now card
can show me the when and where.
Finally, how about being able
to ask for all my purchases
while using Google Search?
Well, these are just some ideas
of how to take good experiences
and making them great.
But how can you give this
experience to your users?
Surprisingly, the answer
is easier than you think.
All you have to do is add
markup to your email messages
and Google takes
care of the rest.
Markup, like what you see here,
enables Inbox and other Google
services to highlight
the important information
from your messages
to your users so they
get exactly what they
need at a glance.
I mean, you're already
sending email to users, right?
You don't need to redo
how you send them.
You're just adding a little
bit more to the email body.
Let's put it this
way-- your messages are
the dessert that
you've already made.
All you need to do
is add the markup,
which are like
toppings, such as nuts,
or sprinkles if you're
allergic to nuts.
In other words, it
doesn't take much effort
to add markup to your messages.
By the way, did you know that
by enhancing your messages
with markup, users are
more likely to engage?
Well, with some of
our partners, they
noticed an increase
of up to 30%.
Inbox supports two types of
markup-- microdata, which
you can see here is
XML flavored, and JSON
for Linking Data,
JSON-LD for short.
Both formats rely on schema.org
for a single standard shared
vocabulary.
Getting started is even easier.
The first link you
see here takes you
to the markup documentation
while the next one
goes through developer tools
to help you create, add,
and validate your markup.
Finally, you can catch more
videos in this and other series
with the links
down at the bottom.
If you need help, search
our Google Schemas tag
on Stack Overflow.
Well, we love great
experiences, right?
As a retailer, restaurateur,
transportation service,
or any modern business,
you can enhance
what you give your
customers by adding
just a little bit of markup
to the messages you're already
sending to them.
Then tools like Inbox by
Gmail, Google Now, Search,
and Calendar will
play their roles
at delivering that
enhanced experience,
highlighting what
matters most to users.
Just think-- the better
the experience you provide,
the more they'll come back to
you and not your competitors.
Well, I look forward to
seeing some awesome email
messages from you soon.
This is Wesley Chun from Google,
and thanks for tuning in.